Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the CIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
Welcome back to the CISP course. So
today we will go through the domain too
that is asset security and this one is a
short domain having about 10%age in
overall system content. So let's get
started. So these are some of the topics
that we will go through
including the information cycle,
information classification and
protection, information
loading informations,
data security controls, asset retention
and asset handling requirements.
So our first topic is information and
data life cycle. So it is pretty uh
straightforward.
We have these six steps during
information or data life cycle and these
are the collect,
store, use, share, scan and destroy. So
in the collect stage data is generated.
This is the first stage where we
generate
or you can also say modify or aggregate
the data. For example, if I give a
simple example when I was writing uh
notes in the slides or when I was
creating this presentation, I was
generating the data. So I generated this
data and now I am here using this data
this presentation this video. The next
step is once the data is generating to
store it somewhere. So data is saved in
a storage system or repository. So in my
case I saved this presentation inside my
laptop hard disk drive inside the local
drive. I could also have saved it inside
the Google drive or inside the cloud. So
you need a storage location. Save the
data once in the step one. Step three is
then the data once generated and saved
is processed and are analyzed by the
users or system. So here I am using this
data that is this presentation in this
video to teach you this this course. So
I am the user. This is the data that I
generated in step one then stored it in
step two inside my laptop and in step
three I am used here during recording of
this video. The next step step four is
to share the sometime then share the
uh data. So data is shared with
authorized external user or system. For
example, I can now share this PPT slides
with you people. uh inside uh this video
in my video description. So if you like
to have these PPT presentation please uh
ask me in comment I will happy to oblige
and share it.
And then the fifth step is retain. So
data is kept or retained or archived for
a predefined period of time. So since
this is my personal data my personality
I have no constraint or no obligation to
retain this data for specific period of
time. However I can retain it archival
is done uh in a storage you can say a
cold storage which is not accessed
frequently. So once I am done with this
video recording, I am done with the
presentation, I can archive this data
inside my external hard drive which I uh
access or use frequently so that I can
free up the space in my uh present in my
uh laptop which I use frequently for
other tasks as well. And the last step
is to destroy the data. So data is
deleted and permanently removed from
storage making it inaccessible and
unusable. So once this data is no longer
required I no longer need it. I can then
permanently delete it. So since this
data is not a very sensitive or
confidential data I can delete it with
simply delete command. But uh
practically inside organization the data
stored in storage is uh confidential
data maybe private data maybe the data
may be PII or PHI data. So these data
then required specific destru
destruction technique so that it is not
access accessible and uh not usable by
any unauthorized uh third party.
So our next topic is information
classification and protection. So first
we need to classify the uh information
and then according to that
classification we protect the
information. So the purpose of
classification is that it ensures data
receives protection based on its value
sensitivity and impact if compromised.
So what does this mean? This means that
let's suppose if a data is of less
sensitivity let's suppose it is we can
say unclassified data. So we don't need
to
uh employ very strong protection because
the protection and security controls
they are not cheap they cost the
organization. So first we need to
determine the value and sensitivity of
data based on its classification and
then accordingly we need to apply the
protection so that a very high sensitive
data gets more protection and less
sensitive data data of low value and
data that have less impact
get the protection and security controls
accordingly. So this helps security
controls. We apply security controls
accordingly based on data value
sensitivity and impact. Access
permission. Similarly, we apply the
access permission as per the
classification as well as handling
procedures. Handling procedure as we
studied in the last slide. Let's suppose
uh we are storing the data. So very high
sensitive data, we will encrypt the data
and then store it. Similarly, as we
studied the last step was destruction.
For less sensitive data such as this
presentation, I will simply delete it.
But very high for high sensitive data, I
won't simply delete it. I will destroy
the hard drive so that it is
inaccessible
classification criteria. So what are
what are some of the criterias that we
need to keep in mind when classifi when
classifying the data and these include
number one is data age. So older data
may lose sensitivity or value over time
and classification may change as data
becomes outdated or less relevant.
So you must have seen this uh uh one
example that comes into my my mind that
recently uh the US President Donald J.
Trump just declassified the JFK
John F. Kennedy assassination files. So
they were very important, relevant and
sensitive at that time at that uh event
or incident happened. But over time its
sensitivity and value decreased. So they
are declassified in US. I think there is
some specific uh time I think 50 years
or something where the classified data
can then be declassified. So the data
age basically the uh lesser the age the
more sensitive is data uh the more
sensitive and value the data has and the
as the data gets older it age inreases
the its value and its sensitivity
decreases.
Next is of course the value. So the
importance of data to the organization
financial operation or strategic affects
its classification. So this is the most
important one. So
the more value the data has to the
organization to its business
the more higher classification level the
data will get if the data is of very
high level uh let's suppose uh of very
sensitive nature and very impactful data
for example of uh it is of high value to
the national security
the highest that classification that
data can get is the top secret. For
example, you can say the nuclear codes
or nuclear assets, they may get this
classification.
Next is the damage impact. So this is a
potential harm to the organization if
the data is lost, altered or disclosed.
For example, reputational, financial or
operational damage. So again, this is
related to value. So if the data is
let's suppose lost or disclosed what
would what impact it would have on the
organizational
uh reputation financial damage or its
operational day-to-day uh business
operational damage. So the higher the
damage higher will be the classification
of data and if the damage is less uh the
classification may be kept low. Next
thing is the legal and regulatory
requirement. So certain data must be
protected according to laws or
regulation such as GDPR, HIPPA which
influences its classification. For
example, if there is specific data, for
example, in US the PHI data or patient
health information must be kept uh
confidential or secret according to this
law. It is obligated through this law
that the PHI data is kept confidential
and undisclosed. Similarly in EU GDPR is
EU as we studied EU law as we studied in
our first uh domain. So in uh EU the
citizens private data are PII PII data
must be kept confidential and should not
be disclosed to unauthorized
uh users and organization.
And the last criteria is the access and
copy. So the number of people who can
access or duplicate the data, the more
accessible or easily copied it is, the
higher the risk, potentially requiring
quicker
classification.
So this one what does the uh number five
tells us? So the number of people who
can access or duplicate the data the
more accessible or easily copied it is
higher the risk potential requiring
trickle uh classification.
So if the data is easily accessible and
it can be copied by many people or it
can be easily copied then the potential
risk of its uh disclosure is higher.
Therefore such data should get higher
classification so that its uh disclosure
or its handling is done accordingly. So
access and copying of data also impacts
the classification of data. The easily
the data can be copied or accessed the
more stricter classification should get
so that it is not closed
uh easily.
So now coming over to some
classifications inside the government as
well as military. So these
classification are
mostly used in government agencies
particularly military and the
classifications include
uh these this is the highest
classification top secret then secret
confidential and unclassified. So the
top secret
is the highest classification in
government or military classification
and unauthorized
disclosure of top secret data could
cause exceptionally grave damage to
national security. As we study it, for
example, if the nuclear codes or nuclear
uh allocation of the nuclear assets is
disclosed, it will pose a very except
exceptionally grave damage to the
national security.
Number two is the secret. So exposure of
secret data could cause serious damage
to national security. So we are uh going
down from exceptionally grave damage to
serious damage. Third is the
confidential. So disclosure could cause
damage to national security. So it could
cause damage but not serious or grave
damage. And last is the unclassified.
So that is information that does not
require protection for national security
reasons. So these are you can say
unclassified or public.
So now coming over to commercial
classifications
and the commercial classification
include confidential, sensitive,
private, proprietary and public. So we
are coming from higher uh sensitive
classification to lower classification
from confidential to public. So
confidential is the highest level and
disclosure could cause serious harms. So
previously you are talking about
government and its agency. Now you are
talking about private organizations as
well as you can also say private parties
and individuals
that uh use these classification
commercially. So confidential is the
highest level and disclosure could cause
serious harm to the organization
reputation financial as well as
operational damage. Next is the
sensitive. So sensitive is important
data and exposure may hurt reputation of
the organization. Third is private. So
it is internal information that must be
kept private and this information
private information should stay within
the organization as the name indicates
it's private. So it uh it should stay
private. And fourth is propriety. So
this is proprietary information is
shared limited with external party or
limited external sharing and uh its loss
reduces compet competitiveness.
So if this type of data is disclosed the
organization may lose some
competitiveness but no reputational or
you can say other damages. And the last
one is the public. So this information
is openly available and no harm is uh
done if this information is disclosed.
Since this is already this information
is openly or publicly available. For
example, an uh organization or uh
commercially available you can say uh
website where all the info regarding the
organization openly shared for the
public consumption.
So now coming over to a very important
slide that is information ownership and
data roles. So these are different roles
that we will study. We will study their
definition and then uh I have uh given
the example of each of these one uh
taking a banking scenarios that how in a
banking scenario we can correlate these
different roles. So first one is the
data owner. So data owner basically
defines or decides how and why data is
used and ensures it is protected
ultimately
accountable for it. So remember data
owner is always the highest management
such as here we can see it is the CESO
it can also be the CEO chief organ uh
chief executive officer or chief
information security officer. So what is
an example of data owner in a banking
scenario? to the chief information
security officer or CISO or head of
compliance acts as the data owner for
the customer account data. They set
policies on access control, data
retention and encryption standard.
Remember
this is one example for the banking
scenario. or any other organization or
any other example the data owner may
either be the CESO or CEO but it is the
point to remember is that it should be
the highest uh someone in the highest
management. Next is the data controller.
So data controller basically determines
the purpose and means of processing
personal data and ensures compliance
with regulations.
So in our example, the bank itself is
the data controller. It decides that
customer data will be collected and
processed to open accounts, process
transaction and meet regulatory
requirements. So inside banking, the
bank itself is the data controller since
the bank collects the data and then
process it.
Third one is the data custodian. So data
custodian basically manages and
safeguards the data on IT system. So now
you are going more specific towards the
IT system according to the policies
defined by the data
owner. So policy as we already studied
in our domain one policy is the uh
higher level document from the
management. So management defines the
policies and these policies are then
acted upon by the other employees such
as data custodian. So the bank's IT
department. So remember the custodian
are the IT guys that manages the data
inside IT system such as you can say the
database administrator, the network
admin. These are our data custodian. So
the bank's IT department ensures that
databases storing customer informations
are encrypted, regularly backed up and
access is logged and monitored.
Next one is the data processor. So data
processor basically processes or handles
data on behalf of the controller without
owning it. So, so data controller were
basically responsible for processing uh
the personal data but
data controller can also outsource the
data to the data processor and then the
processor process or handle data on
behalf of the data controller without
owning it. So data processor does not
own the data. It simply process it on
behalf of the controller. So data
controller in our banking scenario
example is a third data processor in our
example is a third party maybe a third
party payment processor like a credit
card clearing service that handles
transaction data on behalf of the bank
but does not actually own the data.
Next one is the data user. So user
basically accesses and uses the data to
perform authorized business tasks on the
data. And what is an example of data
user in our banking example? So a bank
teller or customer service agent
accesses a customer's account detail to
process a withdrawal or update contact
information. So for example, if a
customers come to the bank wants a
withdrawal, the person to which he goes
is basically the data user because that
person uses the customer data to perform
that specific action. So a data user is
the one that accesses and uses data to
perform authorize business tasks on the
data. And last one is the data subject.
So these are the the individual whose
personal data is collected, processed or
stored and these are the customer in our
example who opens a bank account and
provides personal information
details like name, ID and financial
information. So I hope this makes sense.
This slide is very important. You should
know all these uh data roles. what does
uh they mean and you can also understand
their uh purpose through this example so
that you can correlate them any organiz
or any example.
Our next topic is data security control
security controls at different data
states. So data can be at different
states for example data at rest, data in
process and data in transit. what are
some of some common security control
that are applied at data uh during its
different states or stages and we will
also give an example for each. So the
first one is the data address. So at
rest data is stored on a device drive or
server. So in this state data is not
actively being used or transmitted. data
is simply stored or archived.
And what are some common security
controls during data at rest? So these
are basically file system encryption.
This one is I think used inside uh
Windows or Linux I don't fully remember.
Full disk encryption full disk
encryption if we can give an example in
Windows.
Bit Locker. So, Bit Locker is
example of full description. Bit Locker
let you decrypt uh encrypt your whole
drive inside Windows. And similarly,
trust trusted platform module or TPM
chip can also be used to encrypt your
data at rest. For example, a bank
encrypt customer account data that is
stored on its database using EFS that is
uh file encryption system or encryption
file system and secure encryption keys
with TPM.
So TPM is used basically to generate the
encryption keys and store the encryption
keys and is a temperproof chip inside
the uh system mainly inside the laptops
and PCs. We will study uh about TPM in
detail in our upcoming domains.
The next state or stage of data is the
data in process where data is actively
being used or processed in memory by
application.
So this one is the most common method
and also difficult to secure because
data is actively being used. So how do
we secure data during its processing and
some common security control include
memory encryption. So by memory we mean
when the data is processed it memory
such as by memory we mean RAM
secure enclaves. So there are secure
enclaves inside memory where we can
securely process the data access
controls application send boxing. So
these are some of the security controls
for data that is actually being
processed.
An example of uh this
our banking scenario is when a banking
application calculates loan interest
data is temporarily decrypted in memory
and protected by secure enclave
encryption and restricted process
permission.
Third and the last one is the data in
transit where data is moving between
systems or network.
So when you are watching this video data
is uh in uh transit because the video is
being transmitted you can say from
YouTube server to your location or to
your device. So the data is actively in
transit and uh when you open YouTube
w.youtube.com
you can see that at the start it is
https.
So this https is basically for security
control of that data during transit and
so the security control during transit
are SSL/TLS
which is transport layer security.
Previously it was SSL. Nowadays the
latest standard is PLS. VPN which is
virtual private network. IPSEC is also
VPN for uh layer 3 IP security and HTTPS
as I said for browsing the web. We use
the HTTPS
which secure our data and encrypts it
during transit. When a customer accesses
their online banking portal, the data
between the browser and the bank server
is protected using TLS in
HTTPS.
So our next topic is what are some
threats to the data storage. So when
data is stored or data is at rest, what
are some threats to that data?
So we will study these threats, study
their description and then we will uh
study some controls or mitigation of
these threats. The first one is the
unauthorized access to that stored data
and it means un unapproved access to
sensitive data or unauthorized access to
sensitive data.
So how can we control unauthorized
access to sensitive data? We can do it
through strong authentication
through encryption. So strong
authentication you can say let's suppose
MFA multiffactor authentication it is
strong authentication. Encryption is if
your data at rest is encrypted as we
studied even if someone accesses it
unauthorizedly, it will still be
encrypted and won't be uh of any use to
that
uh user or system because it is
encrypted. Anonymization means to remove
the sensitive part of data and make it
uh anonymous. For example, uh if we have
let's suppose a customer account data,
we can
remove all the account information and
only disclose let's suppose few digits
for example last three digit or last
four digit.ization
is a similar uh concept. So we will
study anomization tokenization masking
all these in detail laterally but for
now for example you can for a whole
credit card number you can generate just
a token and use it for example 2 3 4
maybe a token number for a specific
credit card number. Masking is as I
already said by masking all the digit of
credit card and revealing only few
digits so that the uh it is recognizable
that this belongs to this customer but
the whole number is not visible and
layered defense. So you need to deploy
layer defense. uh their defense mean
that you have multiple control so that
if one is compromised you have another
control at work.
The next threat to our data storage or
data at rest is liability or
non-compliance.
So this is failing to meet legal or
regulatory obligations. So the data some
sensitive data such as we studied the
PII is governed by GDPR in EUR or PHI is
governed by PIPA in US. So these should
be keep in mind and how do we comply uh
with these regulation we can do this
through due care by taking due care due
diligence
SLAs with the third parties. So if our
data is with third party let's suppose
with uh cloud provider we can sign
SLAs's service lab agreements with that
cloud provider so that our uh data uh is
taken care of according to the applied
rules and regulation.
Next threat is the denial of service
attack and distributed denial of service
attack.
And during this attacks, the system is
overloaded with uh
flood of traffic which causes downtime
to the legitimate users and how we can
mitigate this or how are uh what are
some of the controls against these
attacks. So these are as we studied in
our domain one redundancy. Redundancy
means that you have let's suppose
multiple redundant server. So that even
if one server is uh knocked out by the
DOS or DOS attack user can be routed to
other available server and the server
services are not affected uh to the end
users. Data dispersion. So data
dispersion means that data is not
located at a single location. So data
may be disported at multiple cloud
location so that if it is unavailable at
one location it uh being processed or
made available to user from the second
geographically dispersed location and
network protection. We can protect the
data through network devices such as
firewalls, load balancers etc. Our next
threat is the data corruption or
destruction. So these are the threat
against the data integrity. So this is
the loss. Destruction is the loss of
data. Complete loss and corruption is
the alteration of stored data. And what
are some controls and mitigation against
these threats? So hashing as we already
studied is
used to preserve the integrity of data.
Similarly, digital signature are also
used to preserve the authenticity,
integrity of data, TPM, antimalware and
proper data sanitization. These all are
used for proper uh destruction as well
as for
uh data integrity. Next is the data
leakage or data breaches. So these are
unauthorized data disclosure
and controls and mitigation against
these threats are access controls again
encryption. So even if the data is
leaked or breached data is encrypted and
would make no sense to the uh
malicious uh actor that disclose the
data or to any user and also monitoring.
So data is continually monitored such so
that it does not leave the organization.
And one such uh procedure or replication
for this purpose is DLP which is data
leakage or data loss prevention which
continuously monitors the data and
checks whenever data leaves the
organization it is prevented or it is uh
the user or the administrator is uh
notified about such incident.
And last threat to the data at rest or
storage data is the accidental media
loss. So media is the storage media or
the storage uh infrastructure that
houses the data. So it is the physical
loss of storage devices such as storage
drive or storage servers.
So what should we do to mitigate such
occurrence or such threat? Again
encrypted. So as we can see we have
encryption almost in most of these
mitigation control because as we studied
for data at restress or data storage
encryption is the most obvious or strong
control. Then secure handling and
transport of uh physical media to
prevent its loss.
So as I uh said about the DLP that data
loss prevention. So what is DLP? So
first of all the definition. So DLP or
data loss prevention includes controls
to ensure sensitive data. For example,
social security number, account numbers
and uh other sensitive information stays
within the organization according to the
policies and standards.
What is the function of DLP? So it
detects and then prevents unauuthorized
transfer or exfiltration of sensitive
data. So first of all when DLP is
deployed it first of all uh it is uh
configured and data is fed inside the
DLP. For example the social security
number has specific let's suppose
format. It is given that format that
whenever this format data is uh this
this type of format uh the data of this
format leaves the organization it should
be prevented. So
uh it function is so first of all it
scans the organization all the stoages
and available servers and devices to
discover such data and when this data
whenever it leaves the organization it
prevents it or it uh rings the alarm.
Next is the compliance. So the DLP
basically helps organization meet
regulatory requirements such as HIPPA
and PCIDSS and other data protection
law. PCIDSS is the payment card industry
and data security standard.
Our next topic is data masking
offiscation anonymization and
tokenization. So what are these terms
and how they help us curing our
confidential data?
So let's go through it one by one. So
obiscation is hiding all altering
sensitive data to make it unclear.
An example is replacing real names in
database with random codes. So
obiscation is basically a generic and
broad term and all the remaining three
are you can say examples of the
offiscation. So masking masking is
hiding part of the data using symbols or
placeholder.
An example of masking is showing this
number by hiding or masking the initial
digits such as these replaced by x x
and showing the last four or last three
digit instead of the full social
security number. Similarly, same can be
done for the credit card number.
Remember when you uh call the banking
customer service regarding some query uh
about your credit card or your debit
card and they ask you the last four
digit of your credit card or debit card
number. It is because they themselves uh
are not able to view the whole number
for security reason and for your
privacy. they are able to see the last
four digit and that's why they also
confirm these numbers from you. So
masking is to mask some part of the uh
private data and showing the rest so
that you can make sense of the data but
similarly not disclose the whole data.
Next is the data anonymization and it is
removing or encrypting personal details
so individuals cannot be identified.
So as the name indicates anonymization
is making people's or individuals
anonymous.
So if you have PII data, you can make
this data anonymous by removing the
personal details such as their numbers,
their phone numbers, email numbers, etc.
and replacing these names and other
details with generic IDs for research
data. For example, if we have uh let's
suppose John Smith,
a customer name
We can replace this with a generic ID.
For example, customer
let's suppose 1 2 3. So this is a
generic uh no one can identify John
Smith from this customer 1 2 3.
And another important thing about data
anonymization is that this is
irreversible. So you cannot trace back
customer 123 to John Smith and this once
this data is anonymized this data can
then be used for analysis analytic
purposes and research etc. For example
in university needs some data some
patients data from hospital for their
research. So what the hospital can do
that they can remove the PHI data and
replace it with such generic data and
then the university students and
professor can use that data for their
research for analysis analytic but they
cannot trace back that data to any of
the patient. So important thing about it
is that this process is irreversible.
Next is the tokenization. Sorry, it is
replacing sensitive data with the unique
token while storing the real data
securely elsewhere. For example, a cloud
app sends a token like token 1 2 3 4 5
to represent a credit card number stored
safely in a private database.
As the name indicates tokenization, we
replace sensitive data such as credit
card number with some tokens.
But the uh real credit card number are
securely stored in a database. So this
one the tokenization is reversible.
How? For example, you may have a table
where we have a token. Let's suppose
token 1 2 3 4 5 and this correlates to a
specific
credit card
number. So when needed we can verify
that indeed this token represents this
credit card number. So the difference
between anonymization and tokenization
is one difference is that it is uh
tokenization is reversible.
Anonymization is irreversible. Anonymiz
anized data is basically used for
research and uh analysis analytics.
While the tokenization data is used in
real world scenarios such as in banking
for uh correlating the credit card
numbers with tokens. So that's the
difference this slide is very important
you must understand these concepts.
So if you understand these what is the
masking anonymization tokenization
what's the difference between them uh
then good enough in books you may read
multiple pages about these concept but
uh sometime they may confuse you more
instead of making this concept clear so
I hope it is clear and if you have any
question or confusion you ask in the
comments so our next topic is cloud
storage data protection policies.
What are some consideration or some uh
security measures that we can apply to
data that is stored inside
cloud? So the considerations include
first one is the legal and regulatory
requirement since cloud is a specific uh
infrastructure specific storage types
unlike traditional uh
uh infrastructure where we have a data
center at a specific location data
resides always over there. In cloud the
data is movable. uh you may store it in
some region but you may never know that
it may be in some other continent or in
some other country. So that's why inside
cloud the legal and regulatory
requirements is very important to ensure
all legal regulatory and standards
requirements are documented and agreed
upon before storing data in the cloud
with the CSP that is cloud service
provider. So for example verify that
cloud storage meets GDPR and HIPPA
compliance. What does this mean? This
means that let's suppose in EU GDPR if
you store the EU citizens data it must
uh remain within EU boundary. But in
cloud you may never know the data may be
stored that suppose inside uh China. So
you must know or the cloud provider CSP
must comply with the specific policies
that applies on your data. For example,
if you are if an organization deals with
the EU customers data, then the cloud
provider should
uh comply with GDPR policies by storing
the data inside EU boundary. Similarly,
HIPPA if the data belongs to US patients
data, it must reside inside US boundary
and all other legal requirements such as
its confidentiality.
Data mapping is that identify where data
resides, the type of data, its formats
and its flow across different system. In
cloud we have multiple systems. So you
must know that how data is mapped across
different system. how data goes from one
system to another whether it resides
inside one physical location or it is uh
flows between multiple physical location
for example in cloud we have a cloud AWS
let's suppose region one in one location
one physical location region two in
other physical physical location and for
redundancy the cloud provider may
replicate data from one physical
location to other. So you must know that
how your data flows between these
different region and system so that if
your data is sensitive and it has
certain uh rules and regulation to
comply with you know about all these
things. So for mapping customer data
stored in AWS EU uh Europe region and
track backup location that if your data
resides in EU region uh how the backup
is taken and where is the backup
location because uh most of the time the
backup location is not the same location
for uh two
you can say that backup is always at
some offsite location or at some distant
geographic application so that if this
specific region is struck by a natural
disaster such as earthquake, tsunami
etc. your data is secure at the rom
remote geographic location. So you must
know all these consideration
specifically when your data is stored in
cloud. Next is the data classification
as we already studied it categorizes
data based on sensitivity, compliance,
needs, ownership and business purpose.
So label data as confidential, internal
or public to apply proper control
according to its classification. Policy
based procedures. So follow specific
handling and retention procedures for
each data category according to
organizational policy. So apply
encryption and limited access for
confidential data during retention.
So next topic is data protection
policies that apply to data archiving.
So archiving is also storage but it is
fold storage and data those that type of
data is archived that is not accessed
frequently. So it is archived for legal
purposes. Some regulation may require
that you must retain certain type of
data for specific number of years. For
example, 3 years or five years. But your
organization no longer actively need the
data. Then that type of data is stored
uh or you can say archived
but not used or accessed frequently.
This type of storage is also known as
sometimes as cold storage.
So some data archiving consideration
includes encryption. So if the data is
sensitive, it should be ensured that
archival data is protected from
unauthorized access access. So sensitive
data is always recommended to be stored
in encrypted form so that even if it is
accessed, it is encrypted and of no use
to the one that accesses it. Monitoring
means that tracks access integrity of
archived data to detect enough. So you
once data is archived it should not be
the case that you forget the data. It
should be regularly monitored so that if
someone accesses it you know that who
access the data and why and similarly
you should also ensure the integrity of
archive data so that it remains intact
and is not corrupted. So the uh
integrity anomalies and access anomalies
should be monitored. Next is the
granular retrieval. It means that you
should be able to selectively recover
specific files or data portion in the
archive data instead of restoring the
entire archive. So for example, if you
need some specific files to recover or
to access it should not be the case that
you then need to uh restore the whole
archive data that may be very large. You
should be able to recover specific files
or specific chunks of data.
Electronic discovery or eiscocovery is
the process of finding, securing and
reviewing electronic data for legal or
investigative purposes. So once your
data is archived, you should be able to
search and find specific data inside
your archived data. For example, if you
need some email data or some let's
suppose a customer credit card number,
there should be a way to electronically
search and discover that data. Backup
and recovery. So ensures that archived
data can be restored if corruption or
loss occurs. So if let's suppose there
is some corruption or loss of data you
should be able that you have a get
backup of that archive data and then you
are able to recover that archive data
from the backup. Media type means that
what type of physical or cloud storage
medium is used to store that archive
data. For example, it may be tab, it may
be disk or it may be cloud storage. Next
is the restoration procedure. So this
defines a step for recovering archive
data efficiently and securely.
Our next topic and an important topic is
data remnants. So data remnance is the
residual data left on storage media
after deletion or destruction effort. So
let's suppose you have uh a simple
example a flash drive and let's suppose
you have some data over it and you
simply you insert this flash drive
inside your laptop you have Windows
laptop you right click on this flash
drive and you simply format it or delete
the data. So does this permanently
delete the data or there are ways to
retrieve the data through some means?
Yes, there are ways to retrieve that
data through specific forensic tools and
that concept is known as data rem
in although you deleted the data there
are remnants and
uh data available over there that can be
retrieved. So for sensitive data this is
very important that you know how to
properly
remove or destroy the data without any
possibility of retrieval.
So the risk of data remnance is that
improper deletion can allow unauthorized
recovery of sensitive or regulated data.
Sensitive irregulated data means PHI,
patient health information, confidential
data or top secret
data.
So what are some causes and risk of data
remnants? So simply deleting files only
removes pointers not the actual data.
Temporary files, caches, CPUs, GPUs and
cryptographic system may retain data
traces.
Cloud environments complicate data
destruction in use since users lack
physical drive access. So inside cloud
you don't have direct access to the uh
hard disk drive. So deleting that data
is complicated. We will see uh how that
data can be deleted. What are the
procedure to delete data inside cloud so
that it cannot be accessed. So the cloud
considerations are physical overwriting
or is not possible in cloud uh model
such as pass software as a service and
pass platform as a service. So the
solution is to encrypt the data and
delete the encryption keys and this
process is known as cryptographic
eraser. When you delete the encryption
keys, the data can no longer be
decrypted and so it is erased. The data
is erased or deleted cryptographically
known as cryptographic eraser.
Our next topic is sanitizing media. So
these are different types of media and
these are some of the methods which we
can use to sanitize the data from these
media. And the first type is magnetic
tapes or disc. And the approved methods
are degassing. So degazing remember it
is important degazing is uh exposing the
disc to very strong magnetic fields and
this method is only used for magnetic
tapes and this it does not work again
optical discs, SSDs etc. So you should
uh keep this point in mind that only the
magnetic tapes can be purged or can be
sanitized using degassing which is
exposing them to very strong magnetic
fields. Next is incinerating or you can
also say burning
uh the disc crushing it crushing
crushing the physical disc magnetic tape
and disintegrating them to small
particle of 2 mm.
Next media type is the optical discs
including CD, DVDs and Blu-ray disc. And
again the approved methods include
incenderation, disintegration and
shredding.
So always remember the physical distress
destruction methods are almost always
the most secure methods uh as compared
to other methods such as degassing or
overwriting etc. For SSDs
we can use again the physical method of
disintegration or end generation. The
smart card can be shredded strip
shredded diagonally.
So uh if they are uh shredded diagonally
it is more secure since the you can see
that these strips are very small smart
card. So if they are not spreaded
diagonally there may be chances that uh
data can be retrieved from the strips if
they are let's suppose
spreaded uh vertically or horizontally.
Our
last topic is the sanitization
techniques according to NIS SP NIST
SP808
and these techniques include clearing
which is overwriting
the media with zero and ones and it
gives basic pro protection. So remember
it is not fully secure method and it
should not be used for very sensitive
data. So it gives basic protection. Next
is the purging which is uh
the gauzing to erase magnetic data on
magnetic disk. Next is the destruction
which is the most secure method and it
is physically or logically destroying
data. So mainly it is physically
logically means to encrypt data and then
delete the keys as we studied in case of
uh data deletion inside cloud. Next is
uh zeroing or overwriting which replace
data with random bits or zero. And last
one is the cryptographic eraser which is
deleting the encryption keys that
renders data unreadable.
So that's all for this domain. Thank you
for watching. Please post any question
inside the comments. Stay tuned for my
next video on domain three.